MORGAN FREEMAN: I was a little
kid during World War II.
And following the end
of the war, of course,
glory and bravery and
patriotism instilled in me.
And where do I go?
Air Force.
How'd you feel going in?
So when I joined
the military, I really
did it to serve my country.
But when I got to
the drone base,
I didn't know what I was doing.
They didn't tell me
anything until I got there.
They put me in a small
theater with about 25
other individuals.
And then they played a montage
video of drone strikes.
[explosions]
And Sergeant, after it's done,
he's standing at parade rest.
He's like, your job is to
kill people and break things.
And I was just like, holy
[bleep],, what am I doing?
MORGAN FREEMAN: What is
it like flying a drone?
BRANDON BRYANT: I was an MQ-1
Bravo Predator sensor operator.
So I controlled the
camera and the missiles.
Like, that's my job.
The pilot keeps the
aircraft in the air.
And basically, we
support one another.
If you look out the
window, actually,
if you look down there, that's
kind of the same paradigm view
that we had.
If there's a target to be
attacked, they're like, OK,
this is what's going on.
Or you're going
to watch a person
outside this guy's house.
I mean, you're just waiting
for an opportunity for them
to get into a location, and
you're going to shoot them.
[explosion]
MORGAN FREEMAN: Do you
know how many kills?
13 directly.
My first shot, it was winter,
mountains of Afghanistan.
I killed three people.
[explosion]
Two of them were
obliterated into pieces.
And one of them,
watched him bleed out
and then watched an infrared
become the same color
as the ground that he died on.
MORGAN FREEMAN:
Is there remorse,
or there was like consternation?
BRANDON BRYANT: I'm
sitting there like, I
just watched a man bleed out.
I felt horrible.
I wanted to cry.
I felt-- you know, you feel,
the "this is what I just did,"
the adrenaline rush.
I mean, it was all
sorts of weird--
weird feelings.